on a du mal à faire un repas sans manger
de pâtes m'ont fait attention quand même
[Musique]
quand on a su qu'on pourrait faire des
pâtes en local c'est vraiment on était
obligé ça nous a pas ça nous a paru
tellement clair vous voulez faire ça on
est allé à la rencontre de plusieurs
producteurs de pâtes sèches dans toute
la france qui nous ont super bien
accueilli petit à petit on a monté notre
projet pour le finaliser
au début de cette année donc on
travaille qu'avec des matières premières
de franche comté
c'est à dire que c'est des agriculteurs
bio franc comtois qui travaille avec le
moulin du val d'amour qui eux
travaillent encore à l'ancienne sur mur
de pierre on travaille aussi sur des
gammes de pâtes aromatisées donc là on
recherche que des producteurs locaux
on travaille par exemple avec monthey
milices qui est dans le haut doubs qui
font d'eux des plantes aromatiques dans
nos valeurs il était inconcevable aussi
de mettre que du plastique
c'est pour ça qu'on a réfléchi à un
emballage qui en cellulose de bois
donc il sait qui est compostable à la
maison
on travaille sur trois forme de pattes
les crêtes de coq qu'on fabrique
aujourd'hui donc c'est comme une
coquille est avec une crête de ceux des
fusils donc des sorte de spirale et les
tagliatelles donc des pâtes longue qu'on
enroule à la main on fait des vraiment
les tous les nids à la main
n'utilise 3,3 farine différentes donc le
blé en semi complet le blé complet et le
petit épeautre on mélange de l'eau avec
cette farine on a un temps de malaxage
entre 8 et 10 minutes
une fois que le malaxage est terminée la
machine va verser la cub supérieur dans
la cuve inférieur et où à nouveau et les
malaxer on va venir mettre en fait un
moule qui va nous donner la forme de la
pâte
donc après la pâte va sortir et ensuite
on a un couteau qui vient couper cette
pâte suivant la vitesse du couteau ça
nous donne la longueur
[Musique]
on fait quelque chose qui nous plaît on
est heureux voilà
[Musique]